και έτσι βεβαίως το ερχόμενον καλοκαίρι θα έχουμε να αρκετά σχολία λλά χρόνος μας είναι
πολύ συγκεκριμένος ταν τρία χρόνια χει περάσει ο πρώτος χρόνος εντός τον επόμενο δηλαδή δύο
χρόνο πρέπει να έχουμε τα κληματιστικά και να λιτουργούφι σκα σε όλα τα σχολία δώσαμε
πρωτερειότετας τώρα στη δεύτερη φάση σε λίκια λόγο των εξετάσιων στα οποία σις οποίες χρειάζονται
το μάϊν ιουν ιντα κληματιστικά και ανακοινώνουμεν εντός το νημερόν το δεύτερον και το τρίτων
πλάνο μας για τα επόμενα πενήντα πενντα σχολία υτιώς που επτα χρόνια πονίτα πενίτασχολίς είναι
και η πρώτη φορά που μπαίνουν κληματιστικά γιατί ξέρετε στον ενάμιση χρόνο που είμαστε εδώ
εγώ έχομε λετήσει το σες πολλές αποφάσεις το να μην πουρ ποτέκληματιστικά στα σχολία πότε
ευτυχώς που με την έναρξηντη δικής μα σθητίας υπήρξε και πολιτική απόφαση ναι μπαίνουν κλημαριστικά
και προχθέσει των προϋπολογισμό παρουσιάζοεται κονδίληση γκεκριμένω για κλμτιστικά για πρώτη φορά κάποια εκατομύρια νομίζωστε
πρώτι υπουργός που στην έναρξη του σχολείου παράμονές πήγατε και διανικτερές ας εσχολεί έναι τι
ήταν αυτό που σας έκανε να προχωρήσετε σε αυτό ήταν ένα σεσακά επικοινώνοι απότρικ της
υπουργού ή ήθελε να δει τι κάνουν οι μάθειτα έσείναι πολύ εύκλο να βγάζει τες
ανακινώσεις να κάθεσε σε αναγραφείον για να λές απαγορεύεται η διανικτέρευση σε σχολείω εκείείνη γνωστεί
πίντα όπως στη λέντα παιδιά εγώ νιώθω παραπολύ κόντα στα παιδιά νιώθω ότι όταν τους
μιλήσω θα μου πούν και τους λόγους για τους οποίους υναικείτη τους ωθεί και είχα
εκπλαγεί και εγώ ήδιαπηγαίνοντα σεκεί ήταν πολύ χαρούμενα ήθέλαν να βγάζουν φοτογραφίες μαζί με τους
λέω τώρα τι κάπλούμε εδώ πείτε μου γιατίσαστε εδώ γι ώρα δόδεκα η ραμμια κύρια
θέλουμε να χαρούμε που είνει τελευταία μας χρονια χεται το κάμνεται στο τέλος θ τους
ρωτού θα εγώ σα μαμπα περισότερο θέλω να πω ότι το μίνυμε είναι να ίμα
στε πιοκοντα στα παιδιά για να καταλαβαίνούμε και καλύτερα της συμπεριφορά τους πίσης όταν καταλάβουμε
το